[Music]
it is the best-selling book in history
no volume ever written has been more
loved and quoted and its words sometimes
simple and sometimes mysterious should
always be studied carefully it is the
Bible the Word of God welcome to Bible
answers live providing accurate and
practical answers to all your Bible
questions this broadcast is a previously
recorded episode to receive any of the
Bible resources mentioned in this
broadcast call 885 six seven four seven
once again
that's eight hundred eight three five
six seven four seven now here's your
host from amazing facts international
pastor Doug Batchelor hello listening
friends would you like to hear an
amazing fact have you ever worried about
what you're going to wear or wish you
had more closet space well maboob Ali
Khan never had these concerns the six
Nizam of Hyderabad India who ruled
between 1869 and 1911 had such
tremendous wealth he brought the best
English tailors to Hyderabad to create
his royal robes he insisted on a new
outfit for every single day combining
local tradition with modern styles and
he never wore the same dress ensemble a
second time on one occasion ali khan
liked a particular fabric so much he
bought a five-year supply in advance so
nobody else might wear the same material
her real clothes were this ruler devoted
a whole wing of his palace just to his
wardrobe a 176 foot long corridor with
cupboards on either side his closet and
collection of garments is still
considered among the largest in the
world you know the Bible says the
richest wardrobe in the world cannot
compare with the beauty of a flower to
stay with his friends were going to
learn more on this edition of Bible
answers lie
you're listening to Bible answers live
accurate and practical answers to your
Bible questions hello listening friends
I was getting a drink of water it snuck
up on me
how is everybody welcome to Bible
answers live
we're also streaming this program right
now on Facebook you can watch it either
on the amazing facts Facebook page or
the Doug Batchelor Facebook page and I
am Doug Batchelor my name is Jean Ross
good evening friends and pastor Doug
it's good to have Bible answers live
again this evening live we did something
special last week but tonight we're back
to taking holes before we get to the
program though let's stop with the word
of Prayer
dear father we thank you that we have
this opportunity once again to open up
your word and study together and we wish
to ask in a special way for your
presence and your blessing to be upon
this program I'll be with those who are
listening Lord across the country and
around the world for we ask this in
Jesus name Amen amen
Vasiliy opened the program about
somebody who just well he didn't want to
wear the same garment twice and I'm just
thinking that must be quite the
experience I mean sometimes you you find
a favorite shirt our favorite pair of
jeans that you like to wear I can
imagine what it must be like to try and
fit into something new every single day
be tedious but he he wanted to do this I
guess he was quite a character I read a
little about him and he had a pretty
high estimate of himself a one time when
he was riding the train they wanted him
to get off the train and to walk through
the station to his elephant and he said
no I'm the ruler I'm not walking to my
elephant you're gonna bring the elephant
to the train and he stopped train
traffic for two days until they agreed
to bring the elephant through the
station and to pick him up I guess he
was interested in impressing people but
it's kind of sad he pretty much died
from an alcohol induced coma and when
he's about 40 but he had quite a
wardrobe and you know it makes me think
of where Jesus said in Matthew 6 verse
28 why do you worry about clothing
consider the lilies of the field how
they grow they neither toil or spin and
yet I say to you that even Solomon and
all of his glory was not arrayed like
one of these now if God will so clothe
the grass of the field that's here today
and
tomorrow is thrown in the oven will he
not much more clothe you O ye of little
faith
you know Bible tells us that when the
Queen of Sheba came to see Solomon that
she saw the attire of his servants and
she she had no more breath in her that's
where you get the expression of
breathtaking experience and so you can
imagine when Solomon's garments must
have looked like but Jesus said you know
the flowers are more beautiful than that
God will take care of you and then I
think about the richest man in the world
really wasn't Solomon it would have to
be Jesus I mean because he his father
owns the cattle on a Thousand Hills and
the only thing Jesus owned was a rope
and they took that away at the cross you
know the Bible tells us that they
scattered his other garments in four
parts but they wouldn't tear his robe
they cast lots to see who would get it
and that was a blood-stained robe
because they had taken it off of him
whipped him put it back on and then
brought him to the cross and took it
again
and you know there have been a lot of
you know movies and stuff that have been
made about the robe of Christ but that
robe really represents the righteousness
that he offers us that blood-stained
robe that covers our sin and washes our
robes as white as snow as it says in
Revelation and we have a free offer
tonight if people would like to know
about how can they have their sins
covered by that blood-stained robe and
it's free for asking we'd be happy to
send anyone a book that's entitled the
riches of His grace and it's talking
about this grace that God wants to give
those who put their faith in Him and
we'll be happy to send this to anyone
who would call and ask our resource
phone line is 883 five six seven four
seven and just ask for the book the
riches of God's grace
again that's 800 eight three five six
seven four seven if you have a Bible
question our phone line here at the
studio is 800 four six three seven two
nine seven that'll bring your cold here
to our studio and we're gonna go to our
first caller we've got Glen listening in
Ohio Glen welcome to the program well
thank you for taking my call the pastor
back yeah and an Epicure opening remarks
I've heard it said years ago to do it
hello never wore the same sweater twice
so I thought that might fit into that
really good well in the middle DeMarcos
I don't think she wore the same set of
shoes twice oh yeah there's some people
that they like to change their clothes
and your question tonight I'm a little
sanitary and the reason I am is because
I believe that the seventh day is
according to the lunar cycle that that
was certain I God and when you could
create the calendar by the Passover you
come over the fifteenth of that beard
the first one as being effect a Sabbath
as per the commandment and then the
sixteenth being the first day of the
week obviously the fifteenth becomes a
seventh day and and let my question was
not really a rhetorical kind of a
question but very important to me and
that is that calendar be God use in
Leviticus 23 for and changed to the
lunar calendar in leviticus 23:5
did he change calendars all right let me
see if we can answer your question for
us the Jews operated under two calendars
and you know it's interesting when you
get back to the flood it even tells what
days of the month the flood waters came
and you think well was there a NOAA
calendar but I think that Moses is
taking the calendar that they had as a
Jewish nation their religious calendar
and he's extrapolating backwards what
time of year was the beginning of months
for the Israelites that calendar was
established with the Passover and you'll
find that in Exodus chapter 12 said this
will be the beginning of months for you
and it seems like that the the Jews they
developed another calendar that was more
of a civil calendar that may have
operated the time for the Kings because
the you know they would talk about in
the third reign of this king in the
fifth reign of this king but yeah
there's only I don't know that God
swapped calendars anywhere during the
five books of Moses and I'll you know
with all due respect Glenn we just will
probably respectfully have to disagree
with you I don't think that the the
Sabbath changes from month
based upon the moon I think that there
are two separate cycles of time just
like today the the month and the days of
the week are a separate cycle every
seventh day is when you have the Sabbath
and it's also every seventh days when
you get the first day of the week it's a
seven day cycle that has been repeating
since currie creation and the whole
Jewish nation will bear witness to that
so I think it's hard for us to to
disagree with what we know is 3000 years
of written Jewish history more than that
now of course not only past like do you
have the seventh-day Sabbath but there
were also ceremonial service right that
we read here in leviticus that were
actually part of the religious calendar
and those days could fall on a
particular day of the week because it's
more connected to an actual number in
the month whereas the seventh-day
Sabbath would always be on the seventh
day or on Sabbath or Saturday but the
ceremonial Sabbath could be on a Monday
Tuesday Wednesday it moved
depending upon the year yeah and that
kind of is proof that the the sacred
calendar was separate from the weekly
cycle because some years and though the
sacred calendar was governed by the
moons their months but like you know
Passover was governed by the moon but
some years the Passover fell on the
seventh day Sabbath they called that a
high Sabbath right if the weekly cycle
was always governed by the lunar cycle
they'd never be a conflict it would
always be the same so hope that makes
sense Glen we appreciate your question
next well of that we have is a Kish
listening from Illinois a Kish welcome
to the program hi good evening pastor oz
and good evening pastor bachelor yes
pastor pastor my question was actually
regarding my brother who is a special
kid he is suffering from 75% of mental
retardation and he needs assistance with
activities of daily living and he also
has a loss of the fine motor skills you
know like he cannot close his eyes
voluntarily he can
hold his breath so I had a burden and I
was really thinking that we haven't we
haven't actually tried to get him
baptized by immersion so he hasn't been
baptized all his life and I was
wondering that how is this going to be
in the end you know I was really worried
like is he still gonna be saved because
he doesn't understand much and he's a
baptized so please if you could just
pour your inside yeah that's a good
question and there's probably other
people cost just like you out there that
have loved ones that are handicapped
mentally were they they can't comprehend
you know the spiritual things or maybe
experience a baptism you know one of the
conditions of baptism would be that
you're taught and you understand the
principles of salvation now that's for a
person when they're old enough to have
the understanding and they reach the age
of accountability it's what we don't
baptize babies from what you're saying
it would seem that you know your your
brother he may be handicapped or he he
just can't understand those things and I
would think the Lord is gonna look upon
him as an innocent child and you might
be worried about baptism you know for
your benefit so you guys would have some
peace that he'd be saved but I don't
think the Lord's gonna judge him that
way he's probably gonna judge him like a
child yeah you know God is merciful and
he always takes into consideration the
situation that a person might find
themselves in and sometimes there are
people who are elderly that might not
have any inability mentally to be able
to understand truth but maybe physically
they just don't have the ability they
can't be baptized because they ill or
their own they the deathbed their lack
of being baptized doesn't prevent them
from receiving salvation I think that
would be true of your brother yeah the
Bible tells us that Jesus was baptized
and of course he was not baptized for
his sin Jesus was sinless and so for one
reason Jesus is baptized as an example
for us but I think that Jesus may also
have been baptized in behalf of those
who cannot be like the thief who died on
the cross next
Christ he accepted Jesus he couldn't be
baptized but Jesus said he would be in
the kingdom so you know I think that you
would want to put your brother in that
category and say you know it's just not
practical and it's not going to be an
obstacle to their salvation the Lord is
going to look upon them as innocent
having not reached the age of
accountability and saved by virtue of
the prayers of family mm-hmm absolutely
well thank you for your call on ex
Coley's Patrick listening from
Washington State Patrick welcome to the
program thank you well thank you for
calling appreciate yeah great yeah my
question is related to the idea of
riches and Christ's teachings on and I
know a lot of your listeners probably
probably know these passages about the
how that's uh you know how be a
possibility of a camel going through the
eye of a needle yeah and so um I guess
I'm just trying to figure out like what
he really meant with these teachers are
these serious teachings like visit does
it mean that if one has riches that it's
impossible to enter into the kingdom and
then I guess the full look like what
does it really mean to have riches right
yeah you think about I'm sorry go ahead
sorry well you know you think about like
in our culture especially here in our
country you look at the say that what we
called for but then you compare them to
the poor and a half is it's a Malawi
Africa
and-and-and what we call poor would be
considered very rich right compared to
much of the world we we are very
well-off so does that mean that the
average American is lost because we
qualify as rich and you can't get into
the kingdom of heaven it's that kind of
what you're wondering
well well let me let's talk about the
verse there's a passage and you can read
this in mark chapter 10 verse 23 and
Christ said how hard it is for those who
have riches to enter the kingdom of God
and the disciples were astonished at his
words but jesus said again children how
hard it is for those who trust in riches
to enter the kingdom of God it's easier
for a camel to go through the eye of a
needle than for a rich man to enter the
kingdom of God and they were astonished
beyond measure saying who then can be
saved
and Jesus said with men it's impossible
but not with God now it's interesting
you also find this passage in Luke and
right after this passage when they're
wondering can a rich man be saved it
talks about a rich man named Zacchaeus
who gets saved now keep in mind in the
Bible the David will be in heaven he was
certainly rich Solomon it appears will
be in heaven he was rich Abraham Isaac
and Jacob were all they all had
significant property so God in job you
know was doubly blessed at the end of
his life and he will be saved God is not
saying that a person who has wealth
cannot be saved he's saying a person
that trusts in riches cannot be saved
that young man in this story was afraid
to sacrifice riches and follow Jesus
everyone who really makes a decision to
follow Christ needs to put their heart
and all they are on the altar and then
he wants us to use our wealth and the
ability even to get wealth to be a
blessing to mankind and and you know not
to trust in it because he can all
disappear in a day
some people discovered this in the last
month so I'm going to put you back on
and want to make sure that you able to
hear that Patrick did that make sense
well I think you know I think it's good
for your listeners to at least you know
consider those that's right yeah we
shouldn't strive to be rich yeah and the
parable the parable about the
deceitfulness of riches you know in
appearance or the chokes word that's a
good point
you know I'm looking at another verse
saying first Timothy chapter 6 verse 9
that I think goes along with this this
is Paul writing he says but those who
desire to be rich fall into temptation
and a snare so again it's the the love
of money the desire for riches putting
your trust in
those things yeah now there were a
couple of people think of two or three
rich people came to Jesus rescue at the
end mm-hm
you know Nicodemus bought he was wealthy
and he bought the myrrh to anoint him
and Joseph of Arimathea offered the
grave and says he would make his death
with the rich so you know the Lord is
not disqualifying people but you're
right Christians need to be very careful
about covetousness and easie said a
man's life does not consist in the
abundance of things he possesses good
thoughts Patrick and we're glad you
brought that to our attention at this
time we need to remember our priorities
we've got Joseph listening in
Pennsylvania Joseph welcome to the
program pastor I hope you're both doing
well we are likewise how are you doing
considering how the corner of iris left
the world's economy in a shambles not to
say nothing of the thousands upon
thousands of lives that were lost I was
wondering revelation 6 2 if I may read
it and I looked and behold the white
horse who sat he sat on it had a bow and
a crown was given to him and he went
forth conquering and to conquer somebody
brought to my attention that the word
crown here from the original Greek
translates into the word Corona in the
Italian Bible Spanish Bible
Czechoslovakian Bible and in other
languages and I wonder if there might be
any significance to that probably not
you know there's also a beer out there
called Corona this word in the original
Greek is the word stefanos that's where
we get the name Steven Steven or
Stephanie or it all comes from other
words Stephan oh so you're looking at it
in Latin and I suppose you know there's
probably 10 other languages that it's
translated into that wouldn't say all
different kinds of words but the word
Corona in Latin is halo and that's where
the virus so it's not that this prophecy
talking about the virus the virus is
actually named after the Latin word for
a halo so I do think there are signs
that we are living near the end but I
wouldn't use that verse that way yeah I
found it saying correctly I think the
the virus was named that way because of
under microscope it has
it looks a little bit like a crown at
least the structure of the virus and I
think that's the connection
yeah exactly but the other we're going
to be doing a special program next
Friday night talking about just some of
what the prophecies say in our day and
age and what's happening with the the
world economy and otherwise
did that help Joseph all right all right
thanks for calling next caller that we
have is Kate listening in New York Kate
welcome to the program I've been
searching for the God for a long time
and I'd like to thank pastor Duke for
for your wonderful service and bringing
me to the Lord and I have a question
today okay would you like to share how
do you fast in prayer maybe there is a
there are a few things that you could
recommend and from your personal
experience maybe there's a method that
works for you that maybe it could help
us good yeah thank you Kate good
question I'll I'll just give you a few
points I have a message online you can
see it's all free at YouTube and it's
just called when you fast and so there's
more there but just very quickly there's
several different kinds of fasting
there's a regular fast where you just
don't eat any food and that may last you
might skip a meal might be a day we've
got a friend here that just got done
with ten days of a fasting for a special
series and I think he just drank lemon
juice and to keep some vitamins up so
you might just you know drink some juice
some people go on the juice fast you
want to make sure you've got the medical
health to do that so if you've got like
you know a low blood sugar or something
better and talk to your doctor before
you fast um sometimes people combined a
fast for the time for prayer I find what
I'm gonna fast just to prepare myself I
have to plan the date a few days ahead
so I just brace myself when I wake up on
this day be advised now Doug you're not
gonna eat and once I've prepared myself
mentally totally a little easier for me
to wake
just say you know this is the day or the
days I'm not eating and and you try and
eat good going up too fast
so you're in good health at that time
and drink plenty of water and it's still
good to get the fresh air and the
exercise and you don't want to do too
much exerting exercise because you you
know you can get faint but most people I
know that fast and do it correctly they
say they feel great yeah absolutely
especially if you can do it hungry but
you can do it for a day or two you know
sometimes takes a day or so to really
start feeling feeling the benefits of
fast yeah but absolutely it's good for a
person's health and it peers the mind I
think that's that's the focus people
fast for different reasons but I think
if you're gonna combine prayer and
fasting you want to make sure that you
take time to spend extra time perhaps in
prayer maybe there's a particular burden
that you have maybe there's somebody
that needs prayer because of bad health
you know you can kind of make that the
focus of your prayer absolutely so thank
you Kate we appreciate your call next
one of the behalf is let's see we got is
that the Selenia I don't know you say
that from Lancaster California the Sully
hi how are you how do you say your name
Cecily okay welcome and your question
why did God make the world well you know
parents get together and they say we
love each other we want to share our
love let's have a baby to share our love
with and God the Father and the Son and
the Holy Spirit they said we love to
love others let's make a world of people
we can love and so they enjoy God enjoys
loving creatures and giving life and
giving joy so he made this world and it
was a beautiful paradise when he first
made it the devil came and messed things
up but when God first made it it was a
beautiful paradise and he wanted to
share this joy in love with Adam and Eve
so good question
can you you're welcome thanks so much
for calling and Thessaly you would enjoy
our amazing adventure program you can
have your folks go to the amazing facts
website we got a program just for kids
that are like eight to 12 years of age
yeah yeah all right well thank you for
your call we appreciate that Ronnie's
calling from Tennessee Ron welcome to
the program good evening Pastor Ross and
the only bachelor program I pay
attention to well I'm honored thank you
and your your question tonight Ron is do
angels have souls and if they do could
you give me a Bible reference okay I'm
assuming that angels are souls now what
I mean by that is the Bible seems to say
that when when God creates you know he
took the elements of the world and he
breathed the breath of life into man and
man became a living soul means he became
you know an independent moral agent with
able to you know have abstract thought
and worship God we believe angels also
have freedom and independence because
some angels chose not to worship God
Bible says the Angels and this is in
Hebrews I forget the verse pastor Ross
ministering spirits sent forth to
minister to those who will be heirs of
righteousness and so it does tell us in
Revelation chapter 12 that the angels
that followed Lucifer they made a
conscious decision not to trust God and
to follow Lucifer so they're an
intelligent creatures that are able to
process and make decisions which would
lead me to believe that they they have
souls now the verse you referring to
their pastor bag is Hebrews chapter 1
verse 14 talking about the Angels says
they're ministering spirits sent forth
to minister for those who will inherit
salvation we don't have the word soul of
attached to angels in the sense that we
would have that of created beings and
it's also interesting that the word soul
in the Bible is not only used for human
beings it's even used for any living
creature when it talks about the souls
in
the seed I talking about during the time
of the flood so it means created life
that we have here on this earth so I
hope that helps a little bit
yes yeah that's what I was after because
I was reading yesterday I was reading
revelation and talking about Satan's
angels being in Chains and held in
reserve for the day of judgment right
yeah and I mentioned that both in the
book of Jude and in Peter but yeah I
think you're on the right track they are
intelligent creatures that they're being
punished because they made the choice
and the fallen angels meaning pastor
Ross we get 21 seconds so if you're
standing by we do see Sir Charles and
Anthony and janessa Sophia stand by we
do have a few lines open if you want to
call in with a Bible question we're
gonna be back right on the other side of
this break with more Bible questions
during this important time when people
are sequestered at home
stay tuned Bible answers live will
return shortly
if you enjoy hearing solid biblical
answers on Bible answers live you can
have those same insights at your
fingertips through the amazing facts
prophecy Study Bible the updated
hardcover version is available at its
lowest price ever and includes the
complete set of amazing facts 27 study
guides plus a Bible numbers and symbols
charts and eight pages of colorful maps
this best-ever Bible gives you a
biblical cyclope dick index words of
Christ in red chronology of the Old
Testament
along with Doug Bachelors how to study
the Bible feature and much more call us
at AF bookstore to learn more about it
at one eight hundred five thirty eight
seventy two seventy five the amazing
facts prophecy Study Bible stands apart
from other binders giving you the same
solid answers you hear each week on
Bible answers live order your copy today
at AF bookstore calm or by calling 1-800
five three eight seventy two seventy
five what if you could know the future
or what you do
what would you change to see the future
you must understand the past Alexander
the Great becomes king when he's only 18
but he's a military prodigy a hundred
and fifty years in advance Cyrus had
been named wrong was violent they were
ruthless they were determined the Gospel
writers see his death as a fulfillment
of salvation this intriguing documentary
hosted by Pastor Doug Batchelor explores
the most striking Bible prophecies that
have been dramatically fulfilled
throughout history kingdoms in time get
your copy today available now on DVD
blu-ray or USB for more information
visit kingdoms in time.com
[Music]
you're listening to Bible answers live
where every question answered provides a
clearer picture of God and his plan to
save you so what are you waiting for
get practical answers about the good
book for a better life today
if you have a question about the Bible
or living the Christian life call us now
at 800-831-6273
you can also watch what's happening here
on the Facebook page by going to Doug
bachelors facebook page at B Doug
Batchelor Facebook or the amazing facts
Facebook page and you can take a peek at
what's happening here on our studio I am
Doug Batchelor
my name is John Ross and we're gonna go
to our first caller we've got let's see
Phil is listening from New York Phil
walking with the program and you you're
a nice guy and a very knowledgeable guy
you know sometimes you hear even an
evangelical say maybe the Jews of his
day did not do quite the right thing by
Jesus but the other side of that coin
never turns up I was watching a movie
about Jesus he was specifically about
the Sermon on the Mount and the best
question that was asked of him at least
from my perspective a guy in a crowd
says to Jesus rabbi if you are who they
say you are why don't you get rid of the
Romans that's my question all right that
is a good question and in fact you're in
good company because the Apostles ask
the same question of Jesus they said
after Jesus rose from the dead they said
will you at this time restore the
kingdom meaning overthrow the Romans and
and restore the kingdom of David and in
the interests of full disclosure Phil I
am Jewish and well my mother's Jewish
but they tell me that that means I
qualify and my kids bought me a DNA
report and it shows that I am so I am I
guess you would call a Messianic Jew I
believe Jesus was the Messiah and I am
but I'm a you know I'm a sabbath-keeping
I don't need an I'm a kosher eating
Christian Jew and I think it's unfair it
always makes me cringe a little bit when
I hear people say the Jews killed Jesus
because in fact the early church all
believed in Jesus they were Jews and
those who are baptized on pentecost and
all the apostles and the new testament
was written by jews there were some
jewish leaders not all you've got people
like Joseph and Nicodemus that believed
in Jesus and many priests believed in
Jesus and a curse John the Baptist's and
some argue even Josephus believed that
he was the Messiah so it's I think it's
unfair to make it's not like it was all
the Jews they're like in any culture
you've got some fair and unfair people
and there were some scoundrels there in
Jerusalem that were threatened by the
power but a good question would be why
didn't Jesus when he came the first time
use that power to subdue the Romans well
he told Pilate when he was being tried
he said My Kingdom is his Pilate said
are you a king he said yeah but my
kingdom is not of this world yet meaning
he came the first time as a sacrifice
when the Messiah comes again he's coming
as a conquering King came the first time
as the Lamb of God that takes away the
sin of the world every Jew understands
the Passover lamb it's a sacrifice he
comes the next time as the Lion of the
tribe of Judah he comes as a king and he
will then overthrow all of his enemies
so we're gonna bring your volume back up
Phil I I we sometimes bring down the
volume just to make sure we don't get
feedback did that make sense you still
there yeah that was an excellent answer
more than made sense
he's very incisive and I appreciate you
taking the time and making the effort
and I thank you so very much
thank you fella preciate you good spear
all right who's next pastor Ross all
right we gonna go to let's see we got
Kevon in Chicago Kevin walking with the
program hi hi hi you know Doug I'm doing
good
how can we help you - yeah
oh so I I basically had a you know I had
a long kind of statement initially uh so
I kind of don't have a Bible question
specifically but I do have a life
question okay yeah and basically long
story short um you know I was growing up
in you know seven days of n pissed
home like you know and I had a
legalistic father you know and I never
was able to play like basketball growing
up due to you know Sabbath and playing
in the high school team and all that but
it's always been like a regret of mine I
kind of tend to blame you know God and
my father for not being able to play
even though I really wanted to um is
there any way like advice for me though
of how to get past that and not not
nothing it against will feel guilty yeah
yeah well let me jump in and try it I
think I understand your question didn't
we didn't mean to cut you off but let me
let me see if I could take a stab at
that Kevin first of all it doesn't
matter whether you were raised a
seventh-day adventists or whether you
were raised a devoted Sunday Keeper a
lot of kids through history have been
told you know we don't do this because
we're Christians and it might be you
know we're not gonna have a made a
famous movie called Chariots of Fire
about a young man said here's a
Christian missionary said I'm not going
to run even in the Olympics for my
country on Sunday and you know everyone
now thinks he's a hero because he took a
stand like that and so um yeah and I
can't speak for exactly the situation of
what kind of household you grew up in
but you know parents I think do their
best to try to both stand for the Lord
and have values in their home and at the
same time you don't make make growing up
a pleasure
pastor Ross has
whole litter of kids mm-hm and you know
you it's a constant battle now you you
grew up in a pastor's house I did I grew
up in a pastor's home and yeah there
were times where you know especially as
a teenager you want to spend time with
your friends and maybe you want to get
involved I'll say sorry that's right
sometimes you wonder why but you know as
you get older and you begin to look for
God for yourself you begin to understand
the reasons behind why God has said this
is not good this is not good and we're
able to grow in spiritually an
understanding of what God would have us
do you know then all of those things
come into perspective we understand the
reason behind it and as a child you
don't always understand that you might
not have a meaningful connection or
relationship with God and so it does
seem like just a long list of you can't
do this you can't do that so you know
that's not uncommon for for young people
to go through a little bit of a trying
time with a need to figure out for
themselves what do I believe why do I
choose to do what I do yeah and you know
unfortunately today across the board in
Christian churches we find statistically
that we are living in such a liberal
society that Christian kids feel so
restricted because all their friends are
doing everything under the Sun that
there's a mass exodus from Christian
families in from Christ when they get
out to college usually it's around that
college time where kids are leaving the
home you know Kevin we turned you back
up I think probably the most important
thing is you know kind of put the stuff
in the past behind but it would be wise
to kind of find out why you believe what
you believe and make that connection
with God because that's what puts things
in perspective can't go backwards mm-hmm
yeah knowledge that's you all right he
will yet I hope that helps a little bit
we appreciate your standing by and a
good question I'm sure others we're
tuning in all right the next caller that
we have we're gonna go to let's see we
have Lois listening from California
Lewis oh sorry Lois I yeah my question
is how should he Christian approach
culture in such a way as to better
understand the beliefs of the people he
wants to evangelize to without letting
the culture
corrupt him well that is a great
question and you know Paul said I become
all things to all men that I might reach
some for Christ now that doesn't mean
you participate in anything that is a
violation of a Christian principle but
to be aware of what you know the
cultural needs are amazing facts has
well we've done mission work all over
the world you know we've been in Africa
and the islands of the South Pacific in
India we've got you know full-time
people working with us in India and
Russia and all and everywhere I go in
the world orient they got little
different customs and you need to be
sensitive to those things to try to
reach people and you can't usually
figure all of that out in a day or two
but as you live among a different
culture for a while you understand with
what they value and their habits then
you find sometimes the best way to
present the most attractive aspects of
the gospel for them and you know bring
them in to studying the word for
themselves but you never want to
sacrifice a Christian principle you know
I heard one time this is a radical
example but I heard about a pastor that
he was trying to understand this
epidemic of pornography so he thought he
needed to look at pornography to
understand it that was the dumbest thing
in the world he ever did because then he
dressed he scarred his mind and he
became addicted but yeah so you don't
want to you know say I want to reach
alcoholics I'm going to start drinking I
mean I think the point for that is if
you're gonna start doing those things to
try and reach people and then you asking
them to a higher standard and they're
gonna say well if you really believe in
this highest standard why would you
participate in something that you know
he's not right exactly and you gotta
show my hypocritical right thank you
appreciate your question next caller
that we have is Charles listening in
Florida Charles welcome to the program a
pastor Ross pastor Doug have a question
the dealing with the coronavirus I just
recently lost my brother due to cancer
on the ninth of this month
now it's but this whole coronavirus has
been going on could it be that the
reason God is allowing this to take
place
you know that isn't it says like
somewhere that that there's gonna be
people that go to sleep before the Great
Tribulation takes place before the
plagues and everything yes as I can't
stand up to him or bring bring me the
light on that well that there if first
of all we share with you and your loss
and I've lost my brother years ago to
cystic fibrosis and I know even even if
you have a long life together it's still
is it creates a vacuum and I'm sure that
you're gonna miss him but there is a
verse in the Bible and pastor Ross might
be going into it now where it says he
yeah I think it's Isaiah where he takes
him away from the wrath to come I'm
looking at one might be that same verse
job chapter 14 verse 13 it says oh that
you would hide me in the grave that you
would conceal me until your wrath is
passed
then you will appoint a time for me
you'll remember me and then it talks
about if a man dies will he live again
says all the days I will wait until my
change comes you will call and I will
answer so you know there are times where
God might lay somebody to rest and
resurrect them when it comes again
especially the elderly or somebody that
might be struggling with a disease or a
sickness and it's the merciful thing for
God to do it's difficult for us and you
know it's always difficult to lose
somebody that you love but we do have
the promise if they are believing in
Christ
you've got the promise of the
resurrection yeah and so yeah and then
there's another verse I can't lay my
fingers on a right now it says that you
know when none considers that they're
taken away being preserved from the
wrath to come he's shielding his loved
ones so there are some people who are
laid to rest and it may be just because
God knows what we can endure and what we
can't endure and you know it's it's hard
to say we don't know how soon the time
of trouble is going to come we are going
through something of a time of trouble
now but it's yeah this is not that
serious it's I'm hearing people on on
television and radio they're complaining
about having to look at the same decor
and
room they after all and other people are
complaining they're gaining weight cuz
refrigerator is always six feet away oh
I can think to do so that is tough but
it's not like some of the other times of
trouble we read about in in history and
one that I think is coming - all right
well thank you for your coleye next holy
is Janice calling from Bakersfield
janessa thank you yeah thank you I had
two questions the first one was from
Psalms chapter 18 why did David ride the
cherubims to get the art and the second
one was from Genesis chapter 27 why did
Rebecca help Jacob get the blessing all
right now tell me that verse you're
looking at in Psalms again what was it
Psalm 18 you said Psalm 18 and the
particular verse I just wrote down the
chapter okay well I'll let pastor I
looked that one up about the cherubs
it's long Psalm and the reason Rebecca
wanted Jacob to deceive his father the
Bible says that Isaac had favored his
favorite was Esau Rebecca had been told
by the angel when she had twins that the
younger is the one who would receive the
Messianic blessing and she knew that
Isaac was getting ready to put the
blessing on Esau and so she did a little
bit of conniving to get Jacob to
impersonate his brother before their
blind father that he might steal the
promise the vow of the birthright
blessing so she was just using some hid
a family intrigue to try to ensure that
Jacob her favorite got the blessing now
that's happened many times in history
where you know some of these kings had
several wives and several children and
all the wives were jostle to see which
one's gonna get the inheritance do you
find that verse there yes it is Psalm 18
that talks about this and just to kind
of get the context it's talking about
how that David he's praying and he's
calling to the Lord for deliverance and
strength and then it says the Lord
answered him from his temple and it's
about the heavenly temple and the Lord
came down in response to his cry and it
talks about how the earth shook the
foundations of the hills
they quake and it talks about God coming
from heaven he came down with darkness
under his feet he rode upon a cherub and
flew he flew upon the wings of the wind
he made darkness his secret place so
it's really describing the coming of the
Lord and of course that occurred in one
sense when the Ten Commandments were
given and God came upon Mount Sinai and
there was thundering and lightning but
in a broader sense deliverance comes for
God's people when Jesus comes the second
time and he comes with all his angels so
it's a sort of poetic description of
deliverance and Sami team is written as
just reading the heading again David was
surrounded on every side by enemies the
Assyrians in the north Syrians in the
north the ammonites mole bites
to the east the Philistines to the south
and Egyptians David got the victory over
every one of them that had been fighting
and finally I think when he subdued all
the nations that surrounded him he
declared this one beautiful Psalm he had
also been saved from all his enemies in
the hand of Saul well thank you for your
coal on exfoli is a Sofia listening in
Canada Sofia welcome to the program hi
my question is about prayer do we need
to dress in white and wear white head
covering and prayers a certain time of
the night or early morning for prayers
to be answered I was told that the
angels will dwell with us if we do this
and our prayers will be answered that
way you know I don't see any verse in
the Bible that says that we need to
dress in a particular color to have our
prayers answered
you know the priests when they would
minister it's true the priests were
given garments and but that was a
uniform for the priests you know there's
no record anywhere that Jesus told the
Apostles that they were to wear any
particular color when they prayed I
think if this was a mandate he would
have said something about it I don't
read where in the New Testament Paul
closest thing I think you can find
his revelation where it says that the
redeemed have washed their robes and
made them white in the blood of the Lamb
that's spiritually you know in heaven
will probably have white robes you can
pray in whatever robe you've got and who
had her color clothes you're wearing now
there is a verse where it talks in first
Corinthians chapter 11 about when women
pray in public that they should have
their head covered but as you read that
we're led to believe that Paul even
recognizes it was a custom in their
culture that you know when a woman
prayed without her head covered it was
considered in that culture to be
disrespectful you know now if you're
Jewish you don't go into church without
a yarmulke on your head if you are a
Christian you do not go into church with
a baseball cap on they're opposites but
it's a custom of respect so I would say
whatever culture you're in you want to
follow the custom of respect nothing in
the Bible and I don't know any country
in the world says you have to dress in
white to pray mm-hmm
we have no examples of that in the Bible
where people would change in order to
pray I think we have examples of the
Bible of people praying in all types of
different situations some praying from
prison and where they were just wearing
rags others praying with gorgeous attire
like the kings but it's really the heart
that God looks at yeah so that's what's
important
thank you for your call a good question
I'm actually is Diane listening from
Iowa Diane welcome to the program
well it's wonderful to talk to both of
you well thank you likewise but my
question is readings in you know
Revelation when we spend a thousand
years with the Lord and then in other
parts of the scripture it says like a
thousand days it's like a day or a day
is like a thousand years right ticket
so is that millennium is that really a
thousand years that sounds like an awful
long time well yeah if a day is a
thousand years and if we spend a
thousand years that would be 360
thousand years of course that's fine
with me if that's how long we spend but
I think that once you enter eternity the
principle of a day for a year
doesn't
apply there's no need to do that I think
God in Bible prophecy dealing with
timelines on earth uses the day for the
year principle but once you've entered
eternity
you know we've got roughly six thousand
years from creation to our present and
then it makes sense that the millennium
would be another literal thousand years
where the world rests during that time
before he makes a new heaven and new
earth going on at that time I guess yeah
takes a long time now of course this
this more than just one timeline that we
have we have the prophetic timeline
where one day is equal to a literal year
but then you find you're in second Peter
3 verse 8 it says but with the Lord one
day is as a thousand years so you've got
two sets if you're doing dealing with
prophetic time you use a day for a year
principal but here it's talking about a
day with the Lord he's as a thousand
years and I think what's significant
about that is my past that I mentioned
the earth is inhabited for about 6,000
years and then Jesus comes and we get to
spend this 1000 year rest in heaven
before the earth is recreated at the end
of that thousand years so it's kind of
interesting about 6,000 and then 1,000
like the Sabbath of rest when Jesus
comes again well thank you for your cold
I am let's see we've got time maybe for
one or two more we got let's Anthony
Anthony listening New York Anthony
welcome to the program good evening
pastors even in okay yeah loud and clear
okay great
my question has to do with Matthew 24
verses 38 through 40 okay and I'll go
ahead and read in the New King James it
says for as in the days before the flood
they were eating and drinking marrying
and giving in marriage until the day
that Noah into the ark and did not know
until the flood came and took them all
away so in the focus there is Noah and
the taking away of the wicked ones and
so also will be the coming of the Son of
Man be and then it says in verse 40
and two men will be in the field one
will be taken and the other left and I
remember being taught that the wicked
will be because of the context of Noah
and the wicked being taken at that time
that the wicked at the end of the time
will be the ones taken away and in the
sense of you know being destroyed and
the others that were left will be the
righteous but then I was reading a
commentary and it says the exact
opposite yeah I just was trying to
figure what the look what it should be
well that it's a good question and
there's a lot of controversy on it the
the context is and you read it in Luke
when they say where are that the wicked
taken and Jesus said where the Eagles
are where the body is that's where the
Eagles are gathered together when it
talks about the flood came and took them
all away they're taken away in judgment
for the Israelites when they were good
they got to stay in the promised land
when they misbehaved the enemies came
and took them out the Assyrians and the
Babylonians took them away but others
argue that the word taken one taken one
left is taken like taken to somebody and
so they argue know that it's the ones
taken or the ones saved so you know I've
understood that the believers are the
ones that are preserved the wicked are
taken away in judgment and of course
like you say pastor Doug this may be
part of the confusion is there is a
taking for both the wicked are taken
away being judged and destroyed but we
also know when Jesus comes the righteous
they don't stay on the earth they take
into heaven so but there is a verse a
revelation chapter six finishes with the
question for the great day of his wrath
is come and who shall be able to stand
and it's applied there that the
righteous of the ones were able to stand
where's the wicked are the ones who are
taken away they turn to the rocks in the
mountains so yes the righteous are taken
when Jesus comes but the wicked also
taken away in judgment so it could maybe
take it both ways right so yeah hope
that hurts a little bit thank you thank
you
now you we have a book I think that
talks about a Joe Cruz wrote a book on
now on the secret rapture one
can one left is that what it's called I
forget anything anything but silent is
there anything else yeah well let me
think what secret that's that's what it
is and you know that's a great resource
for anybody wanting to learn more about
signs of the second coming and what its
gonna be like when Jesus comes and we'll
be happy to send this to anyone you can
just ask for the book called anything
but secret the number for that is eight
hundred eight three five six seven four
seven and again asked for the book
called anything but secret we'd also
like to let you know this is available
on our website so if you go to the
amazing facts website you can read that
resource anything but secret for free
online
you know I'm looking at the clock pastor
Ross and looking at the phones and we
just like to tell Donella and Kimberly
Anthony is somebody if we didn't get to
your call tonight God willing if the
world doesn't all died from the plague
we'll be here next week
I think we're think things you're
looking up now little by little and so
we know this is a tough time we're glad
we'd still be here to minister and to
share with you folks in and you know
there's a lot of material amazing facts
has to offer online Pastor Ross and I
just completed a attend part revival you
can simply go to the amazing facts
website and look up the new heart
revival you can see they're all archived
there on YouTube as well as the amazing
facts site and keep the ministry in your
prayers too you know people are
sequestering at home right now and we're
doing our best to continue to provide
lots of fresh programming to people to
keep people strong in their faith go to
the amazing facts website that's simply
amazing facts dot o-r-g you'll find
layer and layer of Bible related
material a kaleidoscope of truth you'll
also see a button click donate keep us
on the air god will bless you and God
willing we'll study his word with you
again next week
thank you for listening to today's
broadcast
we hope you understand your Bible even
better than before Bible answers live is
produced by amazing facts International
a faith-based ministry located in
Granite Bay California
[Music]
hello friends pastor Doug Batchelor here
with amazing facts Kareem was divorced
pregnant and very concerned about her
future but God saw her in her desperate
loneliness and confusion and he used a
co-worker to share an amazing fact DVD
that led Kareem to our website here at
the website she studied our life
changing free online Bible studies what
she learned there transformed her heart
and today Kareem has a lasting peace
she's baptized and part of a nurturing
church family now you friend have an
opportunity to help someone today and to
make an eternal difference for more
people like Kareem you're a simple
investment of faith and amazing facts
will keep growing and reaching more
people with God's life-changing word
would you prayerfully consider sending a
gift today
to help others know Christ and the
wonderful truth that changes hearts and
it's easy to make a donation give us a
call at 877 five zero six one seven five
one the number again eight seven seven
five zero six one seven five one or just
visit give dot amazing facts dot o-r-g
or send your gift to p o-- box
10:58 Roseville California nine five six
seven eight thank you for studying the
Word of God with me today and I hope
that you plan now to join me again next
week as we discover more amazing facts
Word of God for life-changing Christian
resources visit AF bookstore calm
[Music]
if you'd like to enhance your study of
God's Word visit our website at WWE for
our free Bible study course and make
sure to check out our online bookstore
at AF bookstore com which offers
thousands of inspiring books DVDs and
more to help you get the most out of
God's Word to take advantage of the
offers you've heard on this broadcast
call us at $887 RG did you enjoy this
program make sure to tell your family
and friends tune in next time for more
Bible answers live honest and accurate
answers to your Bible questions